this queen need a king king king
for life
you know what people are going to be
singing that all day you're welcome
america but it's so catchy but i want to
start this way guys because jennifer
this is the old trl studios i know from
back in the day it's so funny coming in
the door downstairs i was like i
remember this yes you were a frequent
guest here so we pulled up one of your
first appearances oh my god don't roll
take please shantae i want to see that
just watching my mom and how hard she
worked was more of an inspiration to me
as a latina woman
um the hard work the perseverance you
know through hard times and stuff like
that watching her was probably the best
thing i could have ever had
the best thing you could have ever had
you love that
yes ma'am we pulled up one of your uh
one of your first tv interviews too no
yes i don't i don't want that no no no
you cannot leave
[Music]
but what i think is so fun guys look you
were both so young you were both sort of
starting out you had some success
certainly but when you both look at that
what were your dreams back then jennifer
for yourself
you know i always wanted to do all the
things i wanted to sing and dance and
act i felt like at that time it was very
kind of taboo for an actress to want to
make music or be considered you know a
legitimate recording artist
and i wanted to do both i really did and
i would probably you wanted to sing
dance well i was on trl with my first
album i had already done out of sight i
had already done celine i had already
done all these movies
and people saw me more as an actress and
to make that transition was a big deal
and maluma when you look at that video
of yourself you're still so cute you're
so so cute so back then what were your
dreams how old were you number one well
i was i was
16 years old
yeah what were your dreams
well i was still playing soccer uh
yeah because you could have been a
soccer player yeah of course but yes i
went to the studio for the first time i
just fell in love with music and the
music industry and
my family was having like a very
difficult time you know my dad he got
broke uh my parents they got divorced so
that dream was just taking care of my
family and 10 years later we're here so
we talk about the movie mary me it's
come out and i love this this
description of you jennifer they said
jennifer lopez remains the patron saint
of romantic comedies
which i think is because i think we're
all crazy we're all craving a rom-com
these days the whole time i was watching
i go did that happen in her life did
that happen in her life it was a very
meta experience as a performer you're
always kind of putting your best foot
forward but then there's the behind
behind the scenes in the dressing rooms
in your house in the bedroom around your
friends you know your inner circle and
where you really let your true the human
being out
in the movie i got to do that a little
bit and then i look at you maluma
because this is your first movie role
way to go big or go home
the first movie role yeah it was
beautiful he was beautiful and you're
playing but you're playing a cheater
cheater pumpkin eater i know but you
were acting you were yeah that was
bastion that was bastion that's not my
lumo yeah what did the character mean to
you a lot i love it because i got super
connected with bastian too because this
is this guy that he dreams becoming a
huge superstar right of course i don't
feel identified with the part that the
cheating part and all that thing but but
yeah i just feel like this guy he just
wanted to to do good things for for him
for his family and also for
for cat you know when he
screwed up you know he was he wasn't
thinking he was young he was just living
different times of his life this is the
thing about the movie because the crux
of it is about love it's a love story do
you consider yourself a hopeless
romantic
a hopeful romantic i think
i think you know i
i think if you just you keep
kind of
your head down
you take that journey
and believe
that you deserve certain things and that
you're a good person and that if you
treat people right the right things will
come into your life and that doesn't
mean that we don't have
difficult tough moments in our journey i
certainly have in personal relationships
and even in my life and in my career
but i just you know kept believing and
there's a great line in the movie where
you said why do i always keep getting in
my own way did that sort of mirror real
life for you too in some ways
when you said that line i felt that it
was nice in this movie to bring some of
my own personal experience of what you
open yourself up that way at this time i
love acting and it's it's something that
comes very natural to me
but in this movie in some of those
scenes it was harder for me to go there
emotionally because i'm so used to
covering that up for everyone yeah and
so in that setting it felt weird like no
i would never let anybody know that this
hurt me or how how much this affected me
i can't you know i'm okay i'm okay don't
worry about me i'm here i'm gonna sing
the song i'm gonna do the thing yeah
i've been called a hopeless romantic
because i still
believe in love i like what you said a
hopeful romance yes
how do you know jennifer lopez when you
have found the one how do you know that
because you do seem to be in a very
different place yes you know you know
when it's not quite right too you know
and i think we do this thing where we
like we're hopeful yes or hopeless and
sometimes or hopeful right like we do
the thing where it's like well maybe
this could work but when
when you
really really love someone when it's
something that's almost not your choice
it's just that's who you are and that's
who they are you know you do see me you
do know you do seem to know this time
because i do know this time
how will you know when it's the one
everything is organic and natural you
know you don't have to
try to fall in love with someone it just
just happened just it just it just
happened like this you know for me
that's very important because i'm
growing i just want to fall in love to
you know and just just having someone
with me and get out with someone else
and there's something too about the two
of you together we're used to seeing
movies where the guy is older and the
woman is younger yeah but this is the
reverse right here
[Applause]
the same thing look at this
but it works
very he's a charmer
oh very much so i've always know how to
get on your good side trust me i think
of course
i can be self-conscious just like
anybody i remember i was doing this
video were actually bad bunny
and i'm sitting there and i'm watching
it and i'm like
do i look like his aunt in this video
like what
and everybody was like
no jennifer and it was so much and if
you have you look good
i try to be realistic because i'll keep
my feet on the ground can i talk about
the music in the movie because not only
did you
you know you executive produce a movie
yeah you're starring in the movie then
you decide you know what this movie
needs an album that you wrote yeah
and you contributed to the album but you
didn't want it to be a jlo i didn't i
did it because i really felt it was
important to make a cat album a cat
valdez album a bastion album because
these were two characters we were
playing and we were singing in their
voices and then did you ask him to write
two songs or did you say yeah right yeah
yeah i went to the studio right away
it's crazy because i was listening to
unanimous this morning one in a million
yeah and i was with the team and it was
like yo this is this is maluma from 2018
because i felt connected because what
i'm saying in the song
sorry i'm super open right now i'm
saying all these things but whatever i
was saying like like you're wanting a
million and i know that i i ruin our
relationship because i'm i'm a douchebag
and i lived that moment in my life and
i'm super honest right now and then
after that
another chapter of my life i have to
write a song
just similar as a segundo that i was
asking for a second chance
you know so it was beautiful the name of
the movie is called marry me jennifer
should i expect an invitation anytime
soon to a wedding
let's just say jennifer lopez is
madeleine love and she makes no
apologies and doesn't try to hide it
she's very happy she said for the long
time her personal and her professional
life is lined up together in a very
beautiful way the two of them together
really do have chemistry on screen two
of the most charming people on the
planet they really are tony i mean he
has a tattoo of his name maluma uh that
was his first uh tattoo and it's for his
stage name because maluma represents the
members of his family his mom is margie
his father is louise and his sister
what's his sister's name her name is
manuela so the parents were very upset
when they first saw the tattoo and then
they got the name and go maluma we like
it i'm excited about coming out friday
she is the patron saint of romney yes i
agree and she and she likes that mantle
too she likes it
it's a very sweet movie you can get in
the theaters hope you'll go see it in
the movies you need to see it on the big
screen you can also see it on peacock
but go the movie theaters nationwide
this friday